résident madame la ministre
après bordeaux nantes lyon perpignan
agen marseille une nouvelle coupure
géante d'électricité a touché hier le
val de marne
là encore cette coupure a été revendiqué
par la cgt énergie comme une action coup
de poing contre le gouvernement mais
encore une fois ce sont les français qui
sont impactés 135 mille habitants privés
d'électricité et de chauffage pendant la
matinée dix villes touchées ainsi que
l'aéroport d'orly et le marché de rungis
les feux tricolores à l'arrêt ont
provoqué les accidents et les pompiers
ont dû intervenir en urgence les
passagers du train mais ceux d'orly
wallon était bloqué pire des personnes
sont restées prisonnières dans les
ascenseurs
cela ne se passe pas dans un pays
lointain où l'ordre public serait absent
mais dans le val de marne un département
d'un million 4 d'habitants qui touche
notre capitale il est surréaliste une
poignée d'individus comète en toute
impunité des actes aussi dangereux pour
annoncer ensuite publiquement et
tranquillement dans les médias que de
nouvelles coupures vont intervenir
monsieur le premier ministre vous venez
de dire de parler d'actes illégaux
inacceptable et de sanctions mais
quelles sanctions lesquelles monsieur le
premier ministre
expliquez moi ce que vous allez faire
quelles suites concrètes en france
chacun peut-il faire ce qu'il veut sans
crainte des conséquences de ses actes
c'est intolérable et les français n'en
peuvent plus de cette impunité
je vous le demande simplement
concrètement qu'allez vous faire contre
les responsables de ces coupures qui
mettent en danger la vie des français et
pour faire aussi respecter le droit dans
un état où actuellement chacun se croit
tout permis